♪ ♪
>> Emily: A LOT OF A REACTION
TO THE PRESIDENT'S SPEECH LAST
NIGHT BUT NONE MORE WORTHY OF
ITS OWN SEGMENT THAT NEW
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSWOMAN
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ.
>> THE PRESIDENT SHOULD NOT BE
ASKING FOR MORE MONEY TO AN
AGENCY THAT HAS SYSTEMATICALLY
VIOLATED HUMAN RIGHTS.
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD BE REALLY
DEFENDING WHY WE ARE FUNDING
SUCH AN AGENCY AT ALL.
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW WHAT WE ARE
SEEING IS DEATH.
RIGHT NOW WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS
A VIOLATION OF HUMAN RIGHTS.
>> Emily: SHE DIDN'T JUST STOP
AT THAT, SLAMMING I.C.E.
SHE TOOK IT TO A WHOLE 'NOTHER
LEVEL WITH THIS.
>> HE'S FIGHTING AGAINST ALMOST
EVERY WAY PEOPLE CAN ACTUALLY
LEGALLY ENTER THIS COUNTRY,
FORCING THEM TO BECOME
UNDOCUMENTED.
THEN HE'S TRYING TO ATTACK THEIR
UNDOCUMENTED STATUS.
IT'S SYSTEMATIC.
IT'S WRONG.
IT'S ANTI-AMERICAN.
THOSE WOMEN AND CHILDREN TRYING
TO COME HERE WITH NOTHING BUT
THE SHIRTS ON THEIR BACK TO
CREATE AN OPPORTUNITY AND
PROVIDE FOR THIS NATION ARE
ASKING MORE IN AN AMERICAN
TRADITION IN THIS PRESIDENT IS
RIGHT NOW.
>> Emily: ALL RIGHT, JESSE.
SHE WAS SUBJECTED TO SOME
JOURNALISTIC CRITICISM OVER THIS
OBVIOUSLY AND DEFENDED HERSELF
AGAINST IT.
HOW DO YOU RECONCILE, HOW WOULD
SHE RECONCILE THAT WHICH SUCH
SEEMINGLY ARGUABLY MINDLESS
COMMENTS.
>> Jesse: I GETTING AOC FOR
TAG.
-- FATIGUE.
SHE'S EVERYWHERE.
SHE'S ALL OVER THE INTERNET.
I'M KIND OF OVER IT ALREADY.
THINK ABOUT WHAT SHE IS SAYING.
SHE IS SAYING ILLEGAL ALIENS ARE
MORE AMERICAN THAN THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
SHE IS A REVERSE BIRTHER, THE
OPPOSITE OF WHAT TRUMP SAID.
NOW SHE IS SAYING THAT I.C.E.
AGENTS ARE COMMITTING HUMAN
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS.
I.C.E. AGENTS ARE THE ACTUAL
PEOPLE WHO -- SHE IS SAYING IN
THE MIDST OF DECADES, BEST WAGE
GROWTH, GDP GROWTH.
CAPITALISM ISN'T WORKING.
LET'S TRY SOCIALISM?
IT'S THE KIND OF STUFF YOU HEAR
YOUR AVERAGE COLLEGE DEMOCRATS
SAYING YOU KIND OF ROLL YOUR
EYES.
NOW SHE IS A MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
THE TRAINING WHEELS ARE OFF.
SHE IS POPPING WHEELIES THROUGH
THE COUNTRY, THROWING HAND
GRENADES OUT THERE.
SHE IS A PROBLEM NOT FOR
REPUBLICANS.
SHE IS A PROBLEM FOR PELOSI.
THAT'S WHAT I THINK.
CHUCK OR NANCY, HOWEVER.
SHE'S GOOD FOR RATINGS HERE AT
FOX.
>> Juan: I THINK ALL OVER THE
CONSERVATIVE MEDIA UNIVERSE,
THEY SEEM TO DELIGHT AND WHAT DO
THEY CALL HER, AOC.
I MUST TELL YOU, GUESS WHAT, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AGREE WITH HER.
>> Greg: WE ARE A SOCIALIST
COUNTRY NOW?
>> Juan: THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
SAY THE REPUBLICANS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR SHUTDOWN
AND SECONDLY WHEN IT COMES TO
SEPARATING FAMILIES AND CHILDREN
FROM PARENTS, AMERICANS DON'T
LIKE IT.
AMERICANS THINK --
>> Greg: THEY WANT OPEN
BORDERS.
>> Jesse: THEY WANT TO ABOLISH
I.C.E.?
>> Juan: THESE PEOPLE CALM.
FAMILIES AND WORKERS.
REMEMBER WHEN REPUBLICANS SAID
JACKBOOTED THUGS?
IF YOU ARE AN IMMIGRANT AND YOU
SEE YOUR COUSIN BEING RATED AND
TAKEN AWAY.
>> Jesse: I THINK REPUBLICANS
HAVE THAT WHEN THE GUNS WERE
SOLD TO MEXICAN --
KILLED THE BORDER AGENTS.
>> Emily: DANA, YOU ARE SAYING
IT'S MORE OF A PROBLEM FOR
SCHUMER.
>> Dana: DEMOCRATS TRYING TO
GET THEIR 2020 GAME GOING ON
THEY HAVE -- THEY ARE SUPER
HOPEFUL.
THEY THINK THEY CAN MAKE TRUMP A
ONE TERM PRESIDENT.
WE WILL SEE HOW THAT GOES.
IF THEY DON'T WIN BACK THE
SENATE, THEY WILL NOT BE IN A
POSITION OF POWER.
IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT.
I THINK FOR PELOSI, WHERE THE
ENERGY IS IN THE PARTY RIGHT
NOW, IT HELPS IN THE HOUSE TO
HAVE AOC OUT THERE AND ALL OF
THESE THINGS.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO DEFEND THEM
THAT MUCH.
IF YOU WANT TO HAVE POWER IN THE
COUNTRY, YOU HAVE TO WIN BACK
THE SENATE.
I THINK THE MORE SHE'S OUT
THERE, THE MORE DIFFICULT IT IS
FOR CHUCK SCHUMER TO TRY TO MAKE
ANY GAINS ON THE REPUBLICANS AND
THAT THEY ARE MORE LIKELY IN
2020, REPUBLICANS MORE LIKELY TO
KEEP THE SENATE OR EVEN EXPAND
THE NUMBER OF SEATS THEY HAVE.
>> Emily: GREG.
>> Greg: YES.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Emily: WHAT WITH THE
MESSAGING FEE FOR COMPASSIONATE,
MORE MODERATE DEMOCRATS WHO
DON'T AGREE THAT THE HUMAN
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS AND THAT THERE
IS DEATH AND SOME TYPE OF
MODERATE GROUND THAT INCLUDES
THE HUMAN RIGHTS VIOLATIONS
BEING COMMITTED -- APPREHENDED
BY THOSE OF THE BORDER,
ET CETERA.
>> Greg: I DON'T WANT TO HELP
THEM OUT.
I WOULD SAY, OKAY.
SHE'S THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S
TRUMP IN THE SENSE THAT SHE HAS
GALVANIZING SOCIAL MEDIA VIA
EXTREME PRONOUNCEMENTS.
EVERY MORNING, SHE GETS UP AND
SAYS WHAT'S MY "LOCK HER UP," OR
"BUILD THE WALL."
HE ENDS UP ON SHOWS LIKE THIS.
I THINK SHE'S BETRAYING HER
CONSTITUENCY.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION EFFECTS
WAGES.
IT AFFECTS THE JOB MARKET OF
MINORITIES.
THAT'S A STONE COLD FACT.
IT IS, JUAN.
IT IS.
>> Juan: I THINK WHAT'S A
STONE COLD FACT IS THAT
IMMIGRATION HELPS ECONOMIC
GROWTH.
>> Greg: LEGAL.
>> Emily: ILLEGAL, LOW WAGES
AND NONCOMPLIANCE.
LACK OF THE THINGS PEOPLE ON THE
LEFT.
>> Juan: THIS REMINDS ME OF
MITT ROMNEY'S GARDENERS AND
PEOPLE ON TRUMP'S PROPERTY
SAYING THAT WE ARE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
>> Greg: I DON'T FOLLOW THAT.
WHAT I AM SAYING IS THAT CHEAP
LABOR HURTS MINORITIES OR PEOPLE
THAT ARE ON THE LOWER RUNG OF
THE LADDER.
THAT'S A FACT.
THE PROBLEM IS, AND LET ME
FINISH BECAUSE YOU TALKED A BIT.
WE HAVE TO GET OVER THE FACT.
YOU'RE ACCUSED OF BEING SEXIST
IF YOU CRITICIZE HER.
IT'S ACTUALLY SEXIST IF YOU
DON'T CRITICIZE HER.
YOU HAVE TO SAY YOUR IDEAS ARE
OLD.
YOU ARE REFRESHING IN YOUR
DELIVERY.
YOU ARE YOUNG.
YOU ARE EXCITING.
BUT YOUR IDEAS ARE AS DEAD AS
THE SOCIALISM OF THE PAST.
>> Jesse: SHE'S DOING
SOMETHING AND SHE'S NOT TAKING
THE TRADITIONAL HEAT YOU WOULD
EXPECT WHEN YOU CALL A SITTING
PRESIDENT UN-AMERICAN OR YOU
ADVOCATE FOR SOCIALISM OR YOU DO
MEAN THE LAW ENFORCEMENT.
A COUPLE YEARS AGO, I AM OLD
ENOUGH TO REMEMBER DOING THOSE
THINGS, YOU GET HIT PRETTY HARD.
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
SPEESIXTEEN BILL de BLASIO
SCHOOL OF DEMOCRATS.
>> Greg: I THINK THAT HAD BEEN
DONE TO OBAMA.
A FEW CONGRESSMEN I THINK WE CAN
REMEMBER PRESIDENT OBAMA OF NOT
BEING AMERICAN AT ALL THAT
STUFF.
>> Jesse: AND THEY GOT HURT
FOR THAT.
>> Greg: THERE IS A MIRROR
IMAGE TO EVERYTHING IN THESE
PARTIES.
THAT'S THE SAD THING.
ONE SIDE DOES EXACTLY WHAT THE
OTHER SIDE DOES.
>> Dana: I THINK THEY
SHOULD'VE HAD HAD HER DO THE
RESPONSE.
TO COMMUNICATE WITH HER AND